kalt et nathalie atias bonjour merci à
tous les deux d'être en direct sur rt
france alors honneur aux dames
tout d'abord madame nathalie attia ce
que signifie pour vous la nomination
d'une avocate à la tête de l'école
nationale de la magistrature
écoutez d'abord c'est pour moi un signe
de d'innovations et d'audaces puisque se
fait rare de ma part cette école n'a
jamais été dirigée par une femme
donc on va d'abord salué cette cette
ouverture sur sur une femme pour diriger
cette école est évidemment l'ouverture
vers la profession d'avocat en fait
comme l'a dit notre ministre j'ai dû
bien notre ministre puisque que je sache
ce ministère de la justice n'a pas
vocation à être uniquement l'apanage de
la magistrature et c'est là que je veux
c'est là que je ne m'explique pas cette
posture d'opposition qui est affichée
par les magistrats je le regrette mais
en tout cas notre ministre a bien
expliqué que cette que deux mêmes
n'étaient pas l'école de la magistrature
mais celles des magistrats et donc il
faut que les magistrats s'ouvre sur
l'office du juge et qui passe aussi par
un apprentissage qui peut se passer chez
les avocats en tout cas de ce que les
avocats
et quand je les avais aucun ce ne sont
pas mon propos n'est pas corporatiste
mais ce sont les justiciables c'est
comment être que les justiciables
veulent après europe et la justice et
donc pour moi c'est en effet un signe
d'ouverture d'innovation et de courage
monsieur altéré nippon a été lui même
avocat est ce que prêche ici pour sa
paroisse finalement en faisant cette
nomination je dirais le problème des
ports de nommer une femme avocate relaté
de l'onem le problème c'est de critiquer
l'autre soit de l'onem et de discréditer
le m
à cette occasion alors ensuite on peut
mettre des avocats la tête de l'ena la
tête de l'école de police la tête de
polytechnique pourquoi pas aussi mettre
des magistrats dans les écoles d'avocats
pour s'interroger sur l'entretoit d'un
certain rôle d'avocate donc ça c'est un
autre sujet le problème c'est le
discrédit qui porte sur le nm comme
d'ailleurs il temps de porter le
discrédit sur le parquet national
financiers comme si le problème c'était
le parquet national financiers et bas la
corruption alors le parc naturel
financière quand même plutôt efficace
dans la lutte contre la corruption et
même cette fameuse enquête de
l'inspection générale de la justice sur
laquelle ils se font pour faire une
enquête disciplinaire
cette enquête nous dit le parquet
national financiers depuis sa création a
rapporté 7,7 milliards à l'état il ya
actuellement 500 dossiers délicats en
portefeuille il ya une reconnaissance
d'un tissu institutionnel
il ya une recherche d'excellence dans
les procédures et il s'attaque à tout
cela alors en plus il a un intérêt
propre
dans ce dossier puisqu'il avait dans le
dossier des fadettes puisqu'il a
lui-même déposé plainte
il a lui même critiqué le pnf comme une
institution à la dérive
donc voilà il règle ses comptes et ce
n'était pas satisfaisant pour un
ministre de la justice de régler ses
comptes avec des institutions qui sont
sous ses ordres en tout cas sous sa
protection
justement les deux principaux syndicats
de magistrats dénoncent un
affaiblissement de l'autorité judiciaire
par eric dupond moretti est ce que vous
partagez cet avis sur helpe je pense que
le garde des sceaux doit afficher très
haut les valeurs de la justice et avoir
une certaine neutralité au regard des
dos si particulier
qui sont jugés donc ils sont instruits
là il n'y a pas du tout de neutralité il
ya un dossier qui le concernent qui
concerne éventuellement son ami maître
herzog avec lequel il a passé des
vacances et le parquet n'étaient
financiers à faire des diligences dans
ce dossier qui sont peut être
critiquable mais en tout cas
l'inspection n'y a vu aucune matière à
poursuites disciplinaires et monsieur
dupont moretti
trois jours après avoir reçu le rapport
de fonctionnement
trois jours après immédiatement sans
délai va diligenter une enquête
disciplinaire contre trois magistrats
parmi lesquels d'ailleurs bien on a un
qui a vocation à conquérir dans cette
affaire dix minutes
concernant les la correction auto
supposée entre monsieur sarkozy enfin le
trafic d influence
sarkozy et azibert donc la pokal général
de la cour de cassation
c'est une affaire dans laquelle il a
personnellement et sainte-thérèse et il
est immédiatement il ya une procédure
disciplinaire ce n'est pas satisfaisant
on était à la limite de la prise
illégale d'intérêts et vous madame natal
et tias est-ce que vous pensez que eric
dupond-moretti cherche à affaiblir le
temps était judiciaire
écoutez moi j'avoue que j'ai été assez
choqués par parler les propos pas les
mots utilisés dans ses communiqués le
communiqué de presse de ces syndicats de
la magistrature
on parle quand même de nomination qui
viserait à discréditer le m&a phlébite
affaiblir l'autorité judiciaire j'ai lu
également des attaques dangereuses pour
l'état de droit
il y a là des propos qui sont très forts
et à la limite de la caricature pour moi
vous pardonnez moi mais ce qui
discrédite l'autorité judiciaire ce sont
les postures caricaturales
vous êtes un tout petit peu en retrait
mais à peine
par rapport à ces cette posture que je
dénonce ce qui discrédite pour moi ce
sont les états des magistrats qui
agissent hors cadre vous avez parlé de
recherche d'excellence du pmf mais
pardonnez moi est ce que la recherche
d'excellence justifie que des magistrats
agissant hors cadre vous citez des
affaires judiciaires qui sauf erreur de
ma part n'ont pas encore donné lieu à
des condamnations
vous parlez du président sarkozy en
parlant de limites prise illégale
d'intérêt mais sauf erreur de ma part
la présentation est encore un principe
de droit dans notre état donc si vous
voulez éviter qu'on attaque qu'on
attaque de manière dangereuse de l'état
de droit commencer par respecter les
principes essentiels que sont la
présomption d'innocence
de la même manière que venir dire que
dupont moretti et son ami erreurs et il
est parti en vacances je ne vois pas ce
que ça peut avoir à faire dans le débat
dans lesquels moi je suis venu de
manière assez naïve probablement en
pensant que nous allons parler
uniquement de la nomination d'un
telemiroir le laténium ancien vice
bâtonnier
j'ai dit bien anciens parce qu'ils
avaient démissionné mais bâtonnier de
paris qui est le barreau le plus
puissant et le plus réputé au monde je
crois montre que cette nomination va
plus qu affaiblir mais au contraire
donné énormément de crédit à cette école
qui gagnerait en effet à s'ouvrir sur
les autres
si on peut revenir un petit peu sur le
débat qui concerne la formation des
magistrats je pense que c'est quand même
ce qui nous a réunis ce matin faut
savoir que nous à l'école du barreau
en tout cas je vais parler de l'usb2 de
paris ens end et ressort de la cour
d'appel de paris dont j'ai l'honneur de
faire partie du conseil d'administration
nous n'avons pas attendu l'arrivée du
ministre dupont moretti ou de qui que ce
soit pour nous ouvrir dans notre
formation nous avons une équipe
pédagogique qui comprend depuis 2014
sous l'impulsion d'une responsable de la
pédagogie
atenor camara cavarroc 200 magistrats
l'école de formation du ressort de la
cour d'appel de paris a déjà été dirigé
par un magistrat alors certes un juge
administratif mais quand même un
magistrat de mémoire 2000 2003 à 2005
nous avons des directions qui sont
confiées également à des universitaires
c'est le cas en ce moment en pierre
berlioz est notre directeur et son credo
c'est véritablement d'ouvrir la
formation des avocats sur le sur
l'extérieur et donc nous avons des
formations communes avec life vieux
l'association française des jeux
l'entreprise parce que aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut c'est justement sortir de nos
silos essayer de nous ouvrir et de ce
point de vue vous avez une chance
extraordinaire d'avoir avec nathalie
aurait une femme à remarquable une femme
à l'écouté avec laquelle j'ai siégé un
an et donc je vous parle de ce que ça
peu de ceux dont je peux témoigner
c'était un pied très très sensible aux
disques au dialogue et aux relations
magistrats avocats
nous souffrons de part et d'autre je le
sais des deux sets de ce climat et de
ces tensions qui existent entre nos
professions et on en a besoin pour notre
quotidien pour notre exercice quotidien
on a besoin d'avoir des relations
apaisées et de ce point de vue là la
nomination de l'atelier rhorer est un
signal fort que vous devriez saluer et
justement dernière question elle
s'adressera à tous les deux
vous l'avez dit on le climat
actuellement et est assez tendue est ce
que la justice française a finalement
besoin de réformes en ce moment moi je
regrette beaucoup qu'on ait un rapport
de l'assemblée nationale six mois de
travail par des parlementaires sur des
réformes de la justice des propositions
très concrètes et la première de ces
propositions
c'est donner plus d'indépendance au
parquet ce rapport est sorti il ya
quinze jours et on en parle beaucoup
moins comme si encore une fois l'idée
c'était pas de réformer la justice
s'était pas de prendre en considération
la centaine de propositions très
intéressantes qui sont dans ce rapport
mais c'était d'attaquer des institutions
judiciaires et plus que beaucoup plus
que le m j'ai dit ce que je pensais de
la nomination de madame à oreille mais
plus que le mc le bf je veux dire le
problème c'est quand même la corruption
ce n'est pas le pnf et c'est pas la
façon dont une enquête a été gérée par
le plf l'inspection fonctionnant à
d'ailleurs dit qu'il n'y avait pas
matière à poursuites disciplinaires ou
déontologique dans ce dossier alors
effectivement les griefs sont
inconsistants cette affaire va sans
doute faire flop dans un an
mais pendant ce temps là on aura une
tension on aura beaucoup d'énergie qui
aura été dépensés alors que cette
énergie devrait être concentrée sur les
questions de lutte contre la corruption
des grands infractions financières et
peut-être que le problème de beineix et
qu'il qu'il lutte contre la délinquance
des puissants et ça ça dérange bourg
natal et la tasse
le mot de la fin très rapidement le mot
de la fin le faut le mot de la fin j'ai
ce sentiment d'être la plus attachée aux
principes qui gouvernent notre état de
droit il y à des procédures on va
attendre que ces procédures se clôture
avant de tirer des conclusions comme
vous faites si vous parliez donc je
reviens à votre question concernant les
réformes de la justice
puisque des réformes aujourd'hui on a un
vrai sujet c'est l'encombrement de nos
juridictions qui affaiblit nos
magistrats greffiers qui ont besoin et
c'est ça le vrai sujet c'est c'est
l'augmentation des moyens budgétaires
que l'état veut donner et de ce point de
vue je ne peux que saluer les annonces
qui ont été faites par monsieur dupont
moretti et je pense que vous pourriez
vous pourrez vous aussi les saluts et
qui consiste à a donc consisté à
annoncer qu'il allait me coûter beaucoup
plus de magistrats
donc voilà c'est pour moi l'essentiel
c'est voilà que l'augmentation des
moyens de la justice dans l'intérêt
commun des justiciables
avant même les magistrats ne parlons pas
de corporation mais parlant des
justiciables puisque la justice est
dirigée et et adresser nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup
nathalie athias et eric alt d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes respectivement
avocate et ancienne membre du conseil de
l'ordre de paris est
monsieur halte vice-président
d'anticorps